hi my name is Chad Daniels I have a new
special on Amazon Prime called dad
chanyeol's and I am going to try to
answer the Internet would you rather
have to average kids there we go or one
kid who goes on to be a pro athlete and
one kid who never learns how to read we
are so close to this not learning how to
read with my son the way it is that if I
could push my daughter into professional
figure skating which I know she'd love
then I don't think we're far off on this
one so plus average kids have you met
him yep
you get one hundred thousand dollars to
put your baby in a microwave for three
seconds do you do it here's the deal if
it's not filmed I do have to turn the
microwave on oh you do I thought okay
I'm thinking you shut the door count to
three open it up baby of course not what
do you it's one of those shows where I
get busted for answering questions like
this no I would not I would not turn a
microwave on for three you put a [ __ ]
fork in the microwave for three seconds
it starts to spark is that true I have a
question
why have you ever put a pop-tart in the
microwave okay and average that's an
average kid answer alright I would not I
would not put a baby in a microwave and
turn it on for three seconds would you
rather prove aliens are real or prove
ghosts are real
oh man I could not give a [ __ ] I'm not
an alien or a ghost guy I mean it would
be fun okay I do have an answer
I would rather prove aliens are real
just for all the kids I went to high
school with that shoved God down my
throat and up my [ __ ] at the same
time yeah I would rather prove aliens
are real to be like Oh guess what
would you rather watch your
parents have sex every night or join in
one time to make it stop
whoo well my dad's dead so this is this
like would it be a corpse am i watching
my mom be a necrophiliac then yeah
that's fun I could put that on social
media and [ __ ] up my followers big
time so let's do that one because I
don't want to join in that seems a real
nasty even though I'd already been in
there to be fair I did pass through
there one time would you rather be able
to have sex with anyone you want or
teleport anywhere in the world I think
I'd rather teleport yeah because I mean
cuz you can't listen I I was at a comedy
club once and this guy had just gotten
out of prison and he was at the bar
because because he took the bus you get
a bus ticket to anywhere you want to go
and he came to the comedy club and I was
like hey man is it true about all like
the sex that goes on and he goes not
really here's what you do he goes a lot
of guys would save their spit in their
plastic rinse cup and then they would oh
I got a lot of weird looks you're eating
sorry about this this is gonna be a
nasty one save your spit in the rinse
cup and then they would trade cigarettes
for plastic wrap from the kitchen then
they would put the spit in the plastic
wrap they would put a towel around all
of that around their dick and then
they'd put it in between their mattress
and the boxspring and that's what they
would do and they would they would have
pictures I know it's gross I'm just
trying to explain then they then they'd
have picked this isn't me as a guy from
prison they they would have a picture of
whoever they wanted to have sex with and
so if you could just do that and
teleport pretty sad that's pretty
amazing I in no way you want any charges
brought against me for that story
because I was just a story for $10,000
would you carry around an anime body
pillow that looks like a human for one
month have to introduce it as your
boyfriend/girlfriend ten thousand
dollars for a month sure I would do that
that doesn't seem
I know it's not that much money but I
mean I live in a small town that I grew
up in so no one likes me anyways still
so like I could carry that around and
just really bother people where they're
like this is not the Lord's way and be
like well it's my way I [ __ ] this
pillow that's my girlfriend if you could
be any character from any TV show who
would you be I think I'd go Joey from
friends just because no one's ever been
in a group of friends with five or more
people and been allowed to be that
stupid for that long so then he must
have some redeeming qualities it was
unbelievable he started office like this
Italian like we're gonna have sex right
and then at the end of the show is like
a caricature he was a full-blown idiot
couldn't do anything if you could bring
back one person from the dead who would
it be
sure let's see I mean I think I'd bring
back Hitler not like to start again
everyone looked at me like Jesus no not
to start the whole process again but
just like put him somewhere and
everybody gets to like walk by and flick
its dick or whatever that'd be a fun one
right we're like step right up
flick Hitler's dick that'd be good I
think that'd be a nice one would you
rather every time you come it comes out
of your mouth or it's a two-liter
bottles worth I think I would have it
come out of my mouth because because
then you'd really be like patting the
ego of the the woman that helped you get
there cuz you're like you're so good at
this look what happened this has never
happened before right it's like no like
yeah
interesting interesting twist I just
think it would be such a great party
that I would love it just add a party
like you guys aren't gonna believe this
watch this turn around and then just
your head like this you can have sex
with anyone you want but they die
immediately afterward oh this isn't a or
this is a just a zit you can have sex
with anyone you want but they die
immediately after who do you have sex
with a Trump I'm gonna [ __ ] down Trump
because guess what number one you can
say you [ __ ] and assassinated
president show me one other person that
could say that guess what Dad chanyeol's
huge on Amazon after that happens
shameless plug